okay this next story is so sordid and
bizarre and so disturbing that I
struggled with exactly how to lay it out
for you in the simplest and clearest
terms and the clearest way is actually
not chronologically it's almost
backwards and then coming back to the
present so last week or the week before
we learned that New England Patriots the
football team the New England Patriots
the owner Bob Kraft was arrested for
soliciting prostitution at a spa in
Florida and we know that Donald Trump is
good friends with Bob Kraft he said he
was surprised and saddened by the news
about Kraft soliciting prostitution okay
then we learned that the spa massage
parlor where this took place which is
now called orchids of Asia Day Spa has
been implicated not only in prostitution
but potentially in a sex trafficking
ring now this is actually a sex
trafficking ring this is unlike pizza
gate or whatever else this is actually
maybe a sex trafficking operation
according to what authorities are saying
it used to be owned by a 45 year old
Chinese woman named Li yang and that's
the second connection to Donald Trump
for this story because Kraft was busted
there and Kraft his Trump's friend Li
yang used to own it and Li yang happened
to watch the Super Bowl with Donald
Trump at the White House recently okay
but fine no big deal because even though
Li yang knows Trump now and she doesn't
own the place and she insists she never
did anything illegal her presence with
Trump is mere coincidence it doesn't
really matter Trump is in pictures with
millions of people as Sarah Huckabee
Sanders has previously told us except
that Li yang has moved from running
massage parlor spas to selling access to
the Trump family to Chinese
businesspeople now Li yang who goes by
Cindy yang I'll call her that for the
rest of the story she and her husband
run a company called
Gy US Investments LLC they've done that
since 2017 and this is a consulting firm
which helps businesses in the United
States
expand in the Chinese market place but
interestingly they also help Chinese
businesses make high-level connections
in the United States that starts to get
a little bit more interesting they have
pictures of trumps Florida Mara Lago
Resorts and they list that they have
activities for clients which include
getting the opportunity to interact with
the president's as well as the Minister
of Commerce guessing they mean the
Secretary of Commerce and other
political figures and they can also help
you set up White House and Capitol Hill
dinners they are selling access to the
upper echelons of power in the United
States including the closest thing we
have to a royal family right now Trump
and his family the day that this story
broke all of a sudden the G Y us
Investments website stopped working all
of this material connecting them to
Donald Trump has been pulled down off of
the Internet
we've been researching Cindy yang and it
turns out that she's a member of the
president's presidential fundraising
committee she donated a total of sixty
thousand dollars to Donald Trump and to
a PAC that supports him her Facebook
page was filled with pictures of her and
Don jr.
and congressman Matthew gates who's a
big trump supporter and Elaine Chao the
wife of Senate Minority a Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell and
Sarah Palin except that if you try to
find that Facebook page now it has also
been taken down as the scope of this
fiasco has continued to expand and
before the gyu s investments website was
taken down it had a long list of events
at mar-a-lago where you can mingle with
Trump or his family members here's one
such promotion saying that you can hang
out with Donald Trump's sister during
the recent government shutdown Donald
Trump was scheduled to go hang out with
these Chinese business people but the
trip was canceled over the shutdown and
Donald Trump ended up staying in
Washington DC but the business model
here is very clear the same woman who
previously ran a massage parlor which is
now tied up in a prostitution sex
trafficking
we're Bob Kraft Trump's friend and owner
of the Patriots was arrested they are
selling access to Trump and his family
here's a picture of tang wah a president
of some kind of automotive Verve firm in
China with Eric Trump we have a picture
of Don Jr with another Chinese business
person in addition to Tang hua and
before her Facebook page was taken down
Cindy yang had multiple check ins at the
White House at mar-a-lago at Trump
International DC hotels at Trump's
national golf course at Trump Tower New
York City it is stunning so the headline
here is that the person who used to own
the illegal massage parlor where Trump
friend Bob Kraft was arrested for
soliciting prostitution is now running a
business that sells access to Trump's
family this is a massive major story if
Barack Obama had been involved in 5% of
this on mere circumstance and suspicions
alone the right would be calling for his
impeachment but there are lots of other
important stories here as well that go
beyond just the Trump cronyism and
corruption there's a national security
angle here we know that there is
significant Chinese infiltration with
American businesses and there are
security concerns here this is a story
of course about crony capitalism but
it's also about how you can buy access
to the President of the United States
but these Chinese consulting firms are
so often mixed in with Chinese
intelligence services and being able to
so easily buy access to the president
and his family at mar-a-lago is a
national security risk
and then lastly with the massage parlor
prostitution spa portion of the entire
thing
there's also the story of the
legalization of sex work which is
another issue which we've discussed
before but that's the story in its full
scope it requires a whole suite of new
investigations which we might get but at
this point the investigative capacity of
our institutions is stretched almost to
the max and I wonder whether there's
even going to be a
proper and full investigation into this
we know Republicans are under no urgency
to do such an investigation let me know
what you think about this I'm on Twitter
at D Pakman the show is on Twitter at
David Pakman show
and I'll be back with much more right
after this okay this actually seems like
a fake headline but unfortunately it's
real Donald Trump has unleashed a brutal
attack on complicated airplanes after
the horrible tragedy involving a Boeing
737 max airplane flown by Ethiopian
Airlines over the weekend
in a moment I'll show you Donald Trump's
statement about this but I want to first
sort of set it up for you yesterday I
interviewed psychiatrist John Gartner
who has been sounding the alarm from a
mental health perspective on Donald
Trump's behavior for close to a year at
this point if not longer and what doctor
Gartner believes is that Donald Trump's
behavior is indicative of some
combination of cognitive decline mental
illness a pre dementia state or some
again combination thereof and we talked
about a bunch of examples yesterday we
talked about Tim Apple we talked about
Jerusalem and God bless the United
States of America we talked about Trump
walking away at a bill signing without
signing the bill there's so many other
examples of this and just within hours
of this interview with dr. John Gartner
yesterday we have a new example right in
our faces Donald Trump took to Twitter
yesterday and went on a broad-based
attack against modern aviation
technology and complexity arguing that
we need to go backwards in aviation tech
which of course makes no sense as
aviation is safer today than it has
absolutely ever been according to the
numbers doesn't matter to Trump let's
take a look at what he tweeted yesterday
starting with airplanes are becoming far
too complex to fly pilots are no longer
needed but rather computer scientists
from MIT I see it all the time in many
products always seeking to go one
unnecessary step further when often old
and simpler is far better split-second
decisions are needed and the complexity
creates danger all of the
for great cost yet very little gain I
don't know about you but I don't want
Albert Einstein to be my pilot I want
great flying professionals that are
allowed to easily and quickly take
control of a plane this is absolutely
outrageous the world is laughing at us
because our president understands
nothing and is proactively damaging he's
doing harm by virtue of the statements
that he makes so so let's see if we can
break this down piece by piece and you
tell me Pat if I'm missing any important
element of this first of all aviation
has never been safer okay the older
simpler planes Trump is talking about
crashed more often automated flight
controls of different kinds date back to
the early 20th century now what Trump
may be referring to although I don't
even know why I'm being so charitable
here maybe some elements of what are
called fly-by-wire systems where flight
controls are not physically manipulating
elements of the airplane that control
flight but are doing so through
effectively a computer through
electronic means of different kinds and
of course anytime you introduce some
kind of technology there's a risk that
that that technology will fail but
accounting for all of the redundancies
and systems that are in place to
safeguard against that aviation is safer
than ever if we want to tie Trump to
this on one side or the other you could
make the case that his shut down a few
months ago slowed down repairs and
updates to planes by hampering the
agencies that are involved in aviation
safety so on the one hand he's
completely wrong and that there's a
concern about aviation becoming more
dangerous on the other hand if it's not
gotten safer at the fastest possible
rate we could point to Trump's shutdown
as at least one possible reason here and
then of course there's also just the
incredible hypocrisy pad of the fact
that there's no more complicated plane
than Air Force One which is a Boeing 747
which he flies weekly if not multiple
times per week which in addition to all
of the normal complexity of that plan
has all sorts of additional systems
including one that allows for midair
refueling in case of some emergency
where Trump needs to stay in the air for
who knows how long
communication system medical systems etc
this is just dumb on every level
I do really don't think it's even worth
playing point/counterpoint with this one
I think it's just Trump's ego getting
the best of him he views himself as an
authority figure on almost everything
like there are those clips of him saying
that no one knows more about taxes than
me no one knows more about campaign
finance than me apparently the same
thing is true for aviation he just he
doesn't know what he doesn't know and he
has the resources to reach out to people
who actually do know about this stuff
like he could contact the head of the
FAA if he wanted to but he'd rather not
he'd rather just tweet based on his
impulses on these things yeah well this
is weaponized ignorant once again and
that's right I mean the biggest problem
isn't that Trump doesn't know anything
about a lot of the things he talks about
that is a problem don't get me wrong but
that's not necessarily the biggest
problem the problem is he's the
president he believes he's an expert on
everything and therefore he doesn't
listen to actual experts and as far as
the Boeing 737 max I mean there's an
issue with the Boeing 737 max okay it
needs to be sorted out many tragic
deaths as a result there's no denying
that whatsoever two crashes within a
five-month period of the same a version
of the 737 max happening shortly after
takeoff with sort of erratic elevation
change altitudes changes so there's an
issue here and it needs to be sorted out
but Trump's commentary is coming from a
place of total ignorance maybe he thinks
if it's too complicated for him to
understand that no one could understand
it that that's another interpretation
but what you end up with is tweets like
this and it's bad for the aviation
industry it's bad for the tourism
industry it's bad just for people who
have anxiety about flying which is a lot
of people and it's embarrassing on an
international level so there's clearly
something very very wrong with this man
whether it's what dr. John Gartner
pointed out yesterday personality
disorder delusions of grandeur or some
combination thereof maybe we will
someday be able to better sort
out but this is extraordinarily erratic
behavior make sure you're following the
david pakman show on instagram at david
pakman show the rejected voicemail
segment that we have piloted on our
Instagram page people are loving it I'm
getting tweets and emails about it what
we do is we get like a hundred
voicemails a day or some maybe even more
if you consider both both phone numbers
that we have and the the fact that on
weekends they also continue accruing we
only play a handful of voicemails on the
broadcast show each week but we have
taken some what we are calling rejected
voicemails that are just wacky or
unusual in some way shape or form and
we're publishing them subtitled to our
Instagram page at david pakman show so
check that out by following at david
pakman show on instagram while you're
there follow me as well david pakman on
instagram we will take a break and next
I'm going to speak to Hannah gurmann who
is a professor at New York University
we're going to get into whistleblowing
and leaking what is the difference
between the two
how have different administrations
handled whistleblowers and leakers why
is this so important to a free
independent and strong press all of
those questions and more we will deal
with with Hannah gurmann right after
this short break Fox News host Tucker
Carlson is really good at many things
and one of those things is couching what
we all on the Left suspect are really
unsavory and disgusting political
opinions as sort of rock-solid logical
expressions of just where the facts take
Tucker Carlson and he does this so well
that he's really good at appearing not
to be a hateful conservative but a
compassionate one someone who is led to
conservative policy not by pejorative
beliefs about others but because common
sense and his desire for everything to
be better for everyone
has led him to be a conservative that's
sort of the character he's developed on
Fox News it's pretty transparent but
talk
really good at it and it's particularly
effective with the fox news audience
that he caters to he makes the fox news
audience feel like he and they are
right-wing not because they're bad
people or their priorities are wrong or
they are ignorant but for nice fluffy
reasons that everybody can feel pretty
good about except we know that lurking
behind that are the same disgusting
unpolished ideas that we see at Donald
Trump's rallies and that we see outside
of CPAC and case in point there is some
recently unearthed audio which features
Tucker Carlson straight up saying women
are primitive and just need to be quiet
and do what they're told it's shocking
but it's really not all that surprising
when you actually remember Tucker
Carlson years and years ago and what his
career has actually been this both of
these clips are from the Bubba the Love
Sponge show years and years ago but not
so long ago that Tucker Carlson wasn't
an adult with beliefs that he came up
with on his own take a listen to the
first clip you know in my brief
experience you know gets women going is
arguing with them really yeah honey
non-brand I never use it it's true you
debate politics with a woman and just go
you know just full-blown out there
especially feminism if you're talking to
a feminist and she's giving you well you
know men really need to be more
sensitive and this you know actually men
don't need to be more sensitive you just
need to be quiet and kind of do what
you're told and lighten up a little bit
they love it and then we get to the part
about women being primitive so hey let's
go crazy how old are your daughter
14 I love women but they're extremely
primitive their basic they're not that
hard to understand okay so now what
right well Tucker Carlson has put out a
tweet about this where he says quote
Media Matters caught me saying something
naughty on a radio show more than a
decade ago rather than Express the usual
usual ritual contrition how about this
I'm on television every weeknight live
for an hour if you want to
know what I think you can watch so
opting not to do one of these bogus
apologies which people often do I
totally understand his reasoning there
and taking this as an opportunity to
plug his show so what should happen I've
been getting emails from people saying
David are you going to call for Tucker
Carlson's firing David are you going to
call for an ad boycott of Tucker Carlson
no I'm not I mean I'm not suggesting
Tucker Carlson be fired for this these
are common beliefs among Tucker Carlson
and a lot of people in his audience and
a lot of the Fox News audience why would
they fire him for merely reflecting what
the views are of the audience I'm not
going to call for an advertiser boycott
of Tucker Carlson if advertisers
understand that these are Carlson's
views and these are the views of a lot
of his audience if they don't mind being
associated with them it's still probably
a pretty good financial decision to
advertise with Tucker Carlson so I'm not
calling for an ad boycott either I'm
guessing that a bunch of Tucker's new
friends
if Tucker Carlson were to be targeted
for a firing for an ad boycott or
whatever would say this is another
example of the triggered language
policing left who are trying to get him
fired just over jokes and it's
censorship and free speech and bla bla
bla bla bla First Amendment let's just
all agree that we understand this is the
underlying ideology here period the
facade of the smart logical triggering
the lives Libs non-ugly conservatism of
Carlson who's this great debater and has
the moral high ground and the factual
high ground it's just fake okay he's
just that he is a facade for the exact
right-wing beliefs that we know underlie
their ideology period he doesn't have to
be fired Fox News probably is hiring him
or hired him because of that not despite
that if you go and look at the comments
on articles about this leaked or
unearthed audio I guess is a better leak
doesn't really make sense unearthed
audio on Reddit and
The Daily Beast and everywhere that's
writing about it you will find the
comment section riddled with people who
say Tucker is right he should be
applauded there's nothing wrong with
what he's saying women are primitive
they should just be quiet and do what
they're told there's nothing wrong with
what Tucker is saying and if you find it
offensive it's because you're a
triggered liberal that can't handle the
truth so let's skip the Tucker should be
fired
Tucker is exactly where he should be
these views and Fox News and Fox News's
audience is exactly where this stuff all
makes sense and is sort of harmonious
and it's just up to advertisers to
decide whether they're okay with it and
if they are it's going to continue to be
profitable for them to advertise on Fox
News evaluate Tucker on the reality of
what he actually stands for rather than
this vague notion of a guy who has
simply been driven by the facts to be a
conservative and then we can move on
with our day and continue consuming the
media that we find is useful or relevant
to us if you disagree with me if you
think we should be calling for his
firing or for an ad boycott let me know
I'm on Instagram at David Pakman the
show is on instagram at david pakman
show donald trump has presented his
proposed White House budget and it's
outrageous in every way
it's the largest budget ever four point
seventy five trillion dollars now of
course we're all adults here we all know
about inflation we all know about a
growing economy it would make sense that
in raw numbers over time as the country
grows as more and more people live in a
country in raw dollars budgets would
realistically continue to get larger and
larger however it's the specifics of
what's cut and what is increased that
are I would argue downright immoral to
begin with I told you a while ago that
Republicans were and Trump specifically
we're setting up to use the deficit
they've exploded to justify cutting
Medicare and Medicaid in other words
they blow up the deficit and then they
say hey we've got this huge deficit to
deal with now we've got to cut Medicaid
we've got to cut Medicare and maybe even
Social Security
and they are doing it but let's first
start with what is increased in donald
trump's proposed budget that was
released yesterday totaling four point
seventy five trillion dollars the first
increase from donald trump's budget is a
five percent increase to military
spending not only immoral but wasteful
economically we already have by far the
largest military in the world we already
have more than enough firepower and
weaponry to destroy the world many times
over more than would ever be needed if
this is a proverbial or metaphorical
penis size contest of course throwing in
there eight point six billion dollars
for the us-mexico border wall which
remember he is not easily going to get
from the people in the House and Senate
that actually decide on getting him the
money a seven hundred million dollar
line item for school safety now they are
claiming that this does not contain any
firearms requirements but we really need
to dig into the specifics of how its
worded to get a sense of whether the
idea here is to crowbar some money and
for guns and schools which of course be
an absolute disaster funding for dealing
with opioid addiction that's a good
thing ten percent increase to veteran
health care which is of course fine but
we have to consider the total funding
for all types of healthcare and we can't
fully do that until we talk about what
is being cut education voucher program
which is once again a handout to those
who are looking to [ __ ] public
education and to provide money to
charter schools and private schools etc
total disaster and two hundred billion
dollars for infrastructure as we know
infrastructure spending in general is
stimulative it's necessary
we have aging infrastructure in the
United States but the way that Donald
Trump wants to do infrastructure
spending is a crony capitalist handout
to his friends and the way things have
been going probably relatives as well so
these are the notable Trump budget
increases let's
now at the other side of the ledger
which is what is being cut either
partially or fully in Donald Trump's
proposed 4.75 trillion dollar budget
that we saw yesterday starting with one
point nine trillion in cuts to various
safety net programs which includes cuts
in funding for both Medicaid and
Medicare there it is I told you a year
ago they blew up the budget and they
would later say the they blew up the
deficit rather the deficits so big that
we now need to start cutting Medicaid
and Medicare that is exactly what the
Trump administration is proposing but
not just that
also a twenty six billion dollar cut to
the social security disability program
the Trump budget wants to save three
hundred and twenty seven billion dollars
by adding some new work requirements for
adult food stamp and housing recipients
they believe that will kick off a bunch
of people from those programs saving
them three hundred and twenty seven
billion Donald Trump wants to cut
funding for the Environmental Protection
Agency by thirty one percent a last
thing we should be doing right now as we
more and more rapidly destroy our planet
a five hundred million dollar cut to
NASA which I disagree with ideologically
but also even if you're a sort of
national security conservative you
should want to fund NASA because so much
of what NASA does so much of space
exploration and research for better or
worse leads to technologies and
developments that are useful for
national security
seventy percent cut to renewable energy
research exactly opposite what our
priorities should be eliminates climate
change programs at multiple agencies so
different agencies within them have
elements of climate change related
research Trump specifically is
eliminating funding for those programs
within many of these agencies this
includes a fourteen percent cut to the
Interior Department this includes a ten
percent cut to the Education Department
and then there are a bunch of little
cuts you could call it death by a
thousand paper cuts to programs like low
come after-school programs public
service loan forgiveness subsidized
Stafford loans and work-study absolute
disaster another interesting thing I
guess is maybe a word for it is that
Trump is proposing a way to cut spending
on prescription drugs which President
Obama already tried and actually failed
with so it's almost like taking a part
of Obama's health care reform that
didn't work and just trying to breathe
life back into it sort of like he's
tried to do with the coal industry now
you might recall that Donald Trump
promised to pay off the national debt
within eight years if given eight years
as president this budget if it were
approved would not balance for fifteen
years guaranteed we would maintain
massive deficits for fifteen years we
can debate whether deficits are a good
bad medium or it depends but the promise
was that he would pay off the debt in
eight years instead he's doing the
opposite by virtue of these proposals
and tax policy and trade policy and
increasing that deficit he claims that
free college and health care for all are
just too expensive but those things make
sense and instead we're adding 5% to the
military budget not only unnecessary but
immoral and a complete misuse of
resources now I I'm getting to the thing
a lot of people are waiting for me to
say which is Congress actually
determines spending right Congress will
ultimately determine spending levels
this is what Trump is asking for
presidents never get exactly what they
asked for in White House budgets this is
a starting point ultimately it's going
to be up to the House and Senate to
decide how we are going to be spending
taxpayer money Democrats in both the
House and Senate already say that this
budget is dead on arrival you might
recall that even when Republicans
controlled both the House and Senate for
the first part of Donald Trump's
presidency Trump's budgets were not
passed as submitted with Democrats now
the house this obviously is not going to
pass as submitted it's a political
document I don't even think Republicans
would dream of Medicare cuts as we're
ramping up to the 2020 election I am
sure that they value self-preservation
enough to realize that's a bad idea but
as proposed let's take it at face value
as in this is what Trump proposed
because this is what he wants it's
flagrantly irresponsible and also
completely destructive if it were to
become a reality
welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am fair and cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David Pakman today you
can find me on youtube at youtube.com
slash deburring a fire or follow me on
twitter at Ferren balanced you know one
of the things I love about some of these
Trump supporters out there is that
they're just so rabid in their defense
of the president that they don't care if
they make sense in fact some of them
don't even care if their defense of the
president and their desperation to take
down Democrats ends up causing them to
break the law and in case you're not
familiar with what I'm talking about I
am of course referring to Jacob Wall
everybody's favorite Pro Donald Trump
Twitter troll or at least he was until
he got booted off of Twitter for
creating a bunch of fake accounts and
it's actually those fake accounts that
cost him his Twitter feed that also
could land him in legal jeopardy here's
what's happened Jacob Wall recently took
a trip to Minnesota along with the
right-wing provocateurs Ollie Alexander
and Laura Loomer their goal was to make
this documentary film where they were
going to expose how representative Ilan
Omar married her own brother so that he
could become a US citizen that was the
goal of this documentary and along the
way Jacob wall as part of the film that
is now released goes to the police
office not because of what
representative Omar allegedly did but
because he ever seen
to death threat on Twitter and I've seen
the screenshots of it it's a pretty
disgusting message that he has received
from a man by the name of Drake Holmes
the only problem is when he reported
this death threat to the police which he
did in the documentary and they showed
the screenshot of these messages and
that dude's faces right there he didn't
know that in between the time of filming
this and airing it to the public that he
would get busted for all of the fake
accounts he created so how did Jacob
Walz fake Twitter accounts tie into
Drake homes well the simple fact that
Drake homes was a pseudonym or shouldn't
even say suited him it was a fake
account created by Jacob wall
Jacob wall by all available evidence
created a fake account on Twitter just
to send himself a death threat so that
he could make it look like liberals were
after him his life was in danger he
didn't know what he was going to do so
he files a police report says please
look into this find this Drake Holmes
guy who somehow accidentally misspelled
his own name and his Twitter handle by
the way Jacob wall is a serial liar okay
we know that the story came out last
week or a week before whenever it was
that the woman he alleged had been
sexually assaulted by robert muller the
special prosecutor came out and said
yeah it never happened they told me to
do this they actually tricked me into
doing this and that's why i ran away i
had to physically get away from him
which is what happened in the airport
right before if you all remember his
little press conference that he did it
fell apart his allegations against
robert muller fell apart just like his
claims of being threatened have fallen
apart the only difference is what he's
done in this case assuming he did do it
it's 100% illegal it's exactly what
jesse smollett allegedly did
and has now been arrested for and
appeared in court again today to have to
answer for the same thing has to happen
to Jacob wall at this point and to be
honest I think an investigation needs to
be launched to find out what Ali
Alexander and Laurel umer knew as well
because they were in cahoots with Jacob
wall and I find it highly unlikely that
these two provocateurs did not know that
their little compatriot sitting next to
them in their little trip to Minnesota
hadn't created fake accounts hadn't sent
himself death threats and then helped
him film it and report it to the police
now this is bigger than just one Twitter
idiot I think those other two were
involved and I think in order to find
out whether or not they were we need to
have a proper investigation of this and
Olly Alexander claims oh I'm going to
investigate this oh I hope I wasn't
taken for a fool I've been up against
Olly in a debate and let me tell you
it's not that hard to debunk everything
the guy says I did it live on the air I
actually had to pull up info on my phone
because he refused to believe that I was
right and I had to show it to him said
no you are wrong and you were lying be
honest for once I don't think he's being
honest about this I don't think Jacob
wall is being honest and what Jacob wall
has done here with filing this fake
police report is 100% criminal let's
also not overlook the fact that the guy
is being investigated by federal
authorities for his fake accusation
against robert muller jacob wall needs
help and i'm not saying that to be mean
i'm saying that if you go through what
he was saying on twitter like his weird
crazy obsessive responses to donald
trump I truly believe that this kid
needs some help there's something wrong
you know I don't know what it is I don't
know what the answer is but this kid
needs to be in therapy because he needs
to get to the root of what is happening
to him and find the answers he is so
dead
sprut to defend the president and try to
take down the left that he's willing to
break the law to do it
a normal person doesn't think in that
manner but Jacob wall does hopefully
hopefully Jacob wall does get taken in
to custody because I believe he needs to
be in custody not just for these crimes
he may have committed but because this
kid is seriously a little bit not right
and he needs some therapy so they can
help him and make him better there's
still hope there's still a chance but
he's got to get to the root of his
problems instead of trying to take down
everyone even if it's illegal in order
to defend the president dozens of
wealthy parents have been indicted in a
College Admission scandal about 50
people total it includes some famous
actors and actresses like Felicity
Huffman and Lori Loughlin the mom from
Full House has been indicted charges for
the 50 people roughly 50 people include
bribery and fraud all meant to get their
kids into good colleges and universities
presumably better colleges and
universities than their grades intellect
and extracurricular activities would
have otherwise gotten them into big name
schools are involved here Yale Stanford
USC other schools and there were a few
different methods used sometimes it
involved paying college coaches
including to get them to say that their
kids are not only good at a sport that
maybe they play but even good at sports
that they don't play at all
creating staged pictures rowing for
example and getting a coach to say yeah
this is a great rower we should allow
them to come to the school which of
course circumvents the normal sort of
academic admission requirements another
version of the scam and other side of
the scam was paying either consultants
or exam administrators to sometimes let
smarter people take tests for their kids
another version of it was you would get
fraudulent documents
justify extra time for test taking like
on SATs on the basis of a learning
disability that didn't really exist and
then the proctor of the test would be in
on the scam and sometimes they would be
the ones completing the tests for the
students so there are a bunch of
different versions of this and a bunch
of different sides to it but we're
talking about really big money here
sometimes a total of more than a million
dollars per student could be as cheap as
fifty thousand dollars for a test score
could be as much as two hundred thousand
dollars for those fake sports
credentials that I mentioned and this is
criminal in some cases this is horrible
this I don't think you're teaching your
kids any good lessons here but you know
what Pat you are sort of teaching them
realistic ones which are that money and
connections can get people elite status
whether or not they've earned it and
that's actually a realistic life lesson
and in theory conservatives should be
against this because this is essentially
a handout it's not as that the students
are achieving things based on their own
merits they just so happen to have
wealthy parents and you know this is how
wealth is able to stay in families for
generations we don't live in a true
meritocracy of the 400 richest Americans
according to Forbes 60% of them
inherited their wealth and it starts
with this it starts with parents getting
there's two there kids in two wealthy
schools and then it goes from there now
let's be very clear here what we're now
talking about indictments is over the
line into criminality but of course a
system that is so broken to begin with
as is our education system and our
socio-economic system it's obviously
going to be ruined by corruption and
what I mean by that is the following in
this particular case we have crimes
dealing with front businesses a guy
named William singer who was a sort of
facilitating a bunch of what was being
done here and we could spend an hour
just talking about the details of this
illegal version of this influence and
and sort of elite family and wealth a
vicious circle that exists but think
about how not surprising it is in the
car
texts of the larger educational system
college sports okay
college sports are already rife with
corruption it's been like that for
decades some of it legal and some of it
illegal
maybe corruption is not the right term
cronyism and the type of stuff that
we're talking about the college cost
infrastructure is completely out of
control and it is reinforced and
perpetuated in a vicious cycle
by the fact that it's easier and easier
to get student loans with which you can
pay schools more and more money for room
and board every single year student
lending in and of itself riddled with
predatory victimization of students
completely unsustainable in every way
and allowing students to go further and
further into debt in fields that will
eventually never really allow them to
pay off those loans because of wage
stagnation legacy admissions another
practice that just reinforces this
elitism that Pat is talking about and
then you get to where it starts to get
more borderline right so the use of
consultants to help families with advice
totally legal
that also is an unequal advantage many
or probably most people can't afford to
pay College consultants to help get them
into college so then you go from just
advice about how your essay should be
written to someone who actually sits
with you and writes the essay with you
now we're talking about cheating but is
that illegal and it's just a gray area
sliding-scale consider for example the
golden boy Jared Kushner what about
donating to a school and then your kids
get in Jared Kushner's father donated
2.5 million dollars to Harvard right
around the time that Jared Kushner was
applying to Harvard and then Jared
Kushner not surprisingly got into
Harvard what's the difference the
difference is we've decided some of this
stuff is criminal and some of it is not
and by the way you think you have some
idea now why Donald Trump doesn't want
his grades or SAT scores released I
think this scandal actually tells us a
lot about that do we believe that the
Bush family is all geniuses
who on the basis of intellect deserve to
go to the schools that they went to you
be the judge so the the message for me
here is crime is a social construction
in the sense that society decides what
is considered criminal and what isn't
murder okay basically everybody agrees
that should be criminal but then you get
into stuff like lobbying political
donations influence pendulum peddling of
different kinds bribery fraud college
consultants etc some of the stuff is
over the line and some of the stuff is
not and some of the actions in this
College Admission scandal cross the line
into what society has decided as
criminality I get it's not the same
thing to donate a building to a school
versus to pay an expert to write your
kids admission essay I get that it's not
the same but if you do a serious
analysis of the college system both
things we would expect to be going on in
a system that's designed the way our
system is used and both are ways to use
money to get a kid into a school that
they might not otherwise get into so
there's a lot of criticism to go around
parents coaches who accept the bribes
consultants who cross the line but it's
a rigged system some tactics are legal
some tactics are illegal but it's not a
sustainable system in any way and it
allows the rich to have special access
to education which gets them special
access privileged access access to
positions of authority and we continue
to have the same families dominating
society it's how the system works period
what are you teaching your kids when you
do this even if they don't know not
really sure it's not how I would live my
life if I had kids and I think a lot of
people in our audience probably share
that point of view